hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 19 of his City of God Augustine
is grappling with one of the key
questions raised by ancient philosophy
and indeed ancient culture in general
what will make us human beings genuinely
happy genuinely fulfilled what will
realize human nature entirely and
provide us with happiness and there are
a number of different options and
answers that were set forth by
philosophers prior to Augustine and he
considers many of them but he thinks
that there's a fundamental problem with
them that they didn't fully realize
although he does credit the plate inist
with having at least some vague or or
dim idea about how this would actually
work and the point that he's going to
make ultimately is that what we're
really looking for is eternal life or
eternal peace or as he later on says we
can understand this in in other ways by
calling it eternal life in peace or
eternal peace in eternal life now this
is a problem in part because this is not
something that many of the philosophical
systems actually conceived of instead
they were trying to find some way to
enjoy the highest human happiness within
the confines of this earthly existence
are phenomenal temporal whatever you
want to call it the world that we live
in the world that we were born into and
the world that we will die in sooner or
later at least in a bodily sense and he
begins by looking at what Varro has to
say about it somebody who he respects
quite a bit unfortunately we've lost
Faro's works and Augustine takes from
Varro's discussion that human
life is happiest when enjoying all all
of the goods not just some of the goods
but all of the goods of the body and of
the soul so pleasure is a good of the
body the primary goods of primary
objects of nature are Goods of the
body's strength health all of those
things are Goods of the body but then we
also have the goods of the soul and what
are those include primarily the virtues
but he also talks about our intellect or
our memory all the faculties that we
have when they're functioning at their
highest level when we're engaged in
intellectual life when we're not just
engaged in intellectual life by
ourselves as contemplate errs off on the
side but also socially with other people
engaged with the world itself that's
what could make us happy happy yes we
are happy when we enjoy some of these
things we are happier yet when we enjoy
more of them and we are happiest we
enjoy happiness to the fullest we have
superlatively 'no subpoena that in the
end really counts when we have all of
these goods but Augustine is going to
point out that for Christians or as he
says the City of God the way the City of
God looks at this is what we really are
looking for is eternal life and we would
require eternal life in order to be able
to enjoy all of these Goods sufficiently
for example the goods of virtue to
realize them entirely to realize the
goods of social life we would require an
eternity and eternal life is indeed what
ends up being promised in the revelation
that Augustine is drawing upon and
trying to unite to what he thinks is
best in Greek philosophy so the
Christian perspective that he's bringing
to this says eternal life and eternal
peace is what the supreme good is now
what is the implication of that
for trying to have that within this
temporal existence the answer is of
course that you cannot have eternal life
we will die at least our bodies will die
in this existence and he goes on through
much of the rest of chapter 9 or book 19
of the City of God to talk about
different ways in which the present life
as good as it is is pretty screwed up so
I mean you could think about the
pleasures that you encounter and the
pains that come after them or the
longing that you have for those
pleasures again but he begins by talking
about how both the body and the soul can
suffer losses so he talks about
amputation of limbs or you might think
about the aging process right you
gradually lose control and integrity
over this this frame that we call our
body it starts you know exuding things
that you don't want it to or you know
nails get brittle hair turns different
colors or falls out entirely
your bones eventually start to break
down and become more susceptible to
breakage we go on and on and on and on
right there there are so many things
that can damage this body that we have
and it's not just about the body even
the soul itself he says can encounter
these these kinds of losses you have
people who had a wonderful facility of
memory and then cannot remember anything
after a certain point they suffer
dementia he talks about people who wind
up being possessed and even if we don't
believe in that we could think about the
incredible deficits that come about
through mental illness and how they
can't can cascade through social life
and all of these things that can
actually damage both the body and the
soul so in this present life
unfortunately we are subject to that we
we don't have a reliable absolute secure
integrity of body or soul
he also talks about the virtues we can
do our best to cultivate virtue in this
life and some schools of philosophy for
example he mentions the Stoics but you
might also think about the Aristotelian
's or the plainest thought that by
cultivating virtue we would in fact be
happy now the Stoics were more extreme
than the Aristotelian or the playtest
in saying that virtue itself was
sufficient to keep you happy and so
there is this example of the wise man
the sage the person who possesses all of
the virtues and he is on the rack being
tortured and he's still happy a very
paradoxical way of looking at things
Augustine says the virtues even if
you've got them fully developed aren't
going to make you completely happy and
what the Stoics are saying is somewhat
absurd but put that aside for a moment
because hardly anybody has ever even met
somebody who they could consider to be a
sage right a perfectly developed
perfectly virtuous person in the rest of
us the virtues that we do have our
temperance our justice our courage and
our wisdom they have to struggle against
vices we have to struggle to be just
because we'd like to take more than our
fair share we have to struggle to
exhibit fortitude or courage because we
are tempted to say oh I'm going to let
that one pass when when we encounter
difficulties or conflicts we are tempted
to be intemperate to take more than what
our body actually needs because we like
the pleasures or because we're trying to
avoid the pains of addiction and even
wisdom itself as he says by the fact
that it has to distinguish between good
and evil shows us that we live in a
world filled with evils where we still
have to make prudent choices between the
two so the virtues by themselves
display to us although they are some of
the best things in this world that this
world is not where we're going to have
our ultimate happiness he goes on in
talks as well at great length about
social life
in fact he distinguishes four different
circles of social life extending from
the family and close friends all the way
out to the world of other human beings
whether they're from our culture or
country or city or from some other which
most of them will and finally out to the
cosmos itself and either whether we look
at them in a pagan sense as the gods or
in the Christian sense that Augustine is
talking about the good and bad angels
within all of these things these
relationships that we have although we
are social creatures
they're beset by conflicts
misunderstandings attempts to control
each other attempts to impose for
example a common language upon the
entire world to overcome conflicts which
never works so time after time after
time he shows us that our happiness is
not to be found entirely within this
world now what he does tell us towards
the end of this discussion is that all
of this stems from the fact that we are
rational creatures if we were just
animals like the rest of the animals
then we would enjoy the primary objects
of nature like eating and copulating and
laying in the Sun and you know
eventually we'd have to die but we
wouldn't feel bad about it we would
enjoy as much of this world as we could
and develop our capacities you know a
body and perhaps even a soul to what
degree we could but we wouldn't sweat it
the the very fact that we are rational
creatures introduces this possibility of
thinking and in terms of eternity
thinking in terms of what we can't on
our own have well we cannot produce by
our own capacities or powers and what we
cannot find completely in this world
although we can find for tastes of it
traces vestiges we can find something of
it
within this existence so to come back to
the point
what is the supreme good it's going to
be eternal life or eternal peace with
God and this doesn't mean that the world
then becomes terrible and just crap and
let's get beyond it let's kill ourselves
right now because Augustine says the way
in which we actually do in fact to
whatever degree we do earn or merit or
get involved with or turn ourselves
towards this eternal life putting aside
the issue of grace is through the
cultivation of the virtues through
rightly living through living in society
with other people so all of these other
things do in fact matter the world
counts for something but it's not the
place where we can find our complete
happiness it's not the place where we
will find the supreme good that lies
according to Augustine beyond this
earthly existence this present life
you